hi everyone the month of ramadhan is
fast approaching and this is the perfect
time to make significant changes to your
lifestyle I wanted you to have a fit and
also healthy Ramadan so I've created a
28-day workout and as a meal plan just
for you links to all the plans workouts
and as a recipes will be in my
description box below so follow them
print them and be sure to share this on
fasting during the month of Ramadan is
the perfect time to reset your body and
also mind to really understand your
relationship with food and to really
appreciate the food you've been blessed
with let's start popping your mind and
body by making changes to your eating
habits you can do that by reducing on
sugary salty and also fatty foods you
can also start to adapt and adjust your
workout routine and also workout time
according to how you plan to work out
during the month of Ramadan I've also
created several videos to offer you tips
to get you through a fitter and
healthier Ramadan again all links will
be available in my description box below
so let this month be a time where you
really focus on your well-being not just
physically but also mentally and
spiritually as well and I want this
month to be a month where you really
focus on yourself okay tag me in your
progress
hash tag fitter fasting and tag me at a
journal so official
be sure to share this aren't and have a
healthy and happy Ramadan